where do we want to work towards
Perfection the area that most people
seem to be concerned about when it comes
to being overly self-critical is
pronunciation and to me that is the
least important as long as you're able
to be understood that's good enough at
the other end of the spectrum things
like spelling are very important
spelling mistakes reflect very badly on
the writer now in between those two
extremes pronunciation and spelling we
have things like grammar and the related
idea of word usage to me word usage
natural word usage is more important
than details of grammar but both of
those I think we can be a little more
permissive as long as the meaning is
clear so then the question is